the samsung galaxy note is sort of
halfway between a tablet and phone it
has a giant screen on it a 5.3 inch
Super AMOLED display it's a hi-def
screen so it's really good for watching
movies and playing games but it makes
the phone so big that it's difficult to
use one hand you need two hands for
everything from scrolling through pages
to tapping through menus and especially
for typing since you're using two hands
anyway to give you a stylist it's called
the S Pen and it's very well designed
it's comfortable it's easy to use and it
slots into the bottom of the phone so
it's pretty difficult to displace it the
problem is the handwriting recognition
on the phone isn't really that great I
found it was easier just to type
everything that was faster and more
efficient that way finally it's a
gingerbread device it doesn't use the
latest version of Android operating
system Ice Cream Sandwich it's really a
shame here because some of the more
tablet II features would be enhanced
with ice cream sandwich on board it's
three hundred dollars it's a 4g ATT
device and it's available right now